l'émotion est palpable nigeria après
l'attaqué djihadistes qui a durement
frappé l'état du borno dans le nord-est
du pays
samedi une centaine de civils en majeure
partie agriculteurs ont perdu la vie
alors qu'ils travaillaient dans des
champs le 28 novembre en début d'après
midi
des hommes armés sont arrivés à moto et
ont mené une attaque brutale sur des
hommes et des femmes qui travaillaient
dans des champs à cochons b une attaque
qui n'a pas encore été revendiqué et qui
pourrait bien avoir été menés par le
groupe djihadiste boko haram ou bien par
le groupe etat islamique en afrique de
l'ouest dans cette région en proie à une
insurrection djihadistes depuis plus de
dix ans les agriculteurs pêcheurs et
bûcherons de la région sont
régulièrement la cible des islamistes
ils sont accusés de transmettre des
informations à l'armée nigériane ou de
ne pas payer l'impôt réclamé par les
groupes terroristes
un drame condamnée par le président du
nigeria et je condamne le meurtre de ces
agriculteurs dévoués à leur travail par
des terroristes
le pays entier est blessée par ces
assassinats un sens et une attaque
symbolique alors que l'état du borno
voter pour des élections locales pour la
première fois depuis 2008
un scrutin sans cesse repoussé pour des
raisons de sécurité depuis 2009 et
l'émergence de boko haram
on dénombre dans la région plus de 36000
tués et le déplacement de plus de deux
millions de personnes